[Musique]
annick girardin ministre de l'outre-mer
s'est rendu aujourd'hui à saint-andré
pour inaugurer le site où se trouve la
mairie sociale de la commune
il s'agit d'un espace centralisé où
l'usager peut trouver sur un même lieu
tous les services en lien avec le social
une mairie social c'est un guichet
unique
un lieu où sont regroupés les services
du social d'abord le départ blanqui
havre le centre de gravité la maison
départementale ici qui s'occupe des
personnes les plus fragiles les plus
vulnérables mais aussi la caf la cgss le
ccs et de nombreux services de la
commune qui sont regroupées sur un même
lieu
depuis son ouverture en juin 2016 chaque
jour c'est en moyenne 200 personnes qui
se rendent dans ce guichet unique en
facilitant l'accès aux services publics
les usagers sont ainsi mieux orienter et
accompagner dans leurs démarches
tragédies de ce territoire comment leur
faciliter le parcours à la recherche de
solutions pour la problématique du
quotidien de logements son organisation
sur l'essai en coin de garde d'enfants
sur ce qui fait la vie de
au cours de cette visite les élus ont
alerté la ministre sur les problèmes
économiques et sanitaires la réunion
notamment avec la crise de la dengue
le département se mobilise pour contenir
l'expansion du virus sur notre
territoire nous sommes en lien vers
l'état pour justement mettre les moyens
qu'il le faudra notamment le 6 à
disposition de la lutte contre la dengue
après il ya aussi d'autres difficultés
notamment nous passe à tous les plantes
et les projette call home les maraîchers
et les autres personnes qui travaillent
dans le monde agricole
là aussi donc alerté madame annie sur
les difficultés du monde agricole
parce que c'est dans nos compétences ce
département mais aussi dans celle de
l'étape
la ministre a ensuite rencontré les
associations de quartier et échanger sur
le savoir faire et les traditions de la
réunion
[Musique]